j'ai reçu le tout nouveau modèle de la
surface pro de microsoft c'est la
surface prosys on a gelé mise avec le le
petit clavier type cover de vente qui
sera ensemble du coup en un ordinateur
on va se faire un petit tour je la
trouve vraiment intéressante
or il ya des points positifs il ya des
points négatifs et des trucs qui me
plaisent ya des trucs que je trouve un
peu un peu dommage je vous faire faire
un tour complet de cette nouvelle
tablette ordinateur ce qu'on est
vraiment sur un hybride de microsoft et
ça sera à vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire
[Musique]
voici la surface pro 6 2 microsoft
elle est vraiment compact bien si vous
regardez comme c'est quelque chose qui
est assez fin format compact format qui
est intéressant je vais vous montrer un
côté hybride si vous connaissez déjà la
gamme surface je vais pas forcément vous
apprendre grand chose mais c'est un
produit qui est vraiment un entre deux
qui va être aussi bien une tablette
lorsque vous allez leur fermer comme ça
il ya elle va devenir aussi un
ordinateur lorsque vous allez venir
prendre le clavier type cover of que
vous positionnez comme ça ça devient du
coup un petit ordinateur
donc on est vraiment sur un produit qui
est hybride qui va servir aussi bien
pour la productivité qui va servir aussi
bien pour le loisir c'est vraiment un
produit qui est extrêmement polyvalent
et ça qui fait tout l'intérêt de ce
produit qui vous voyez déjà ce qui
frappe tout de suite c'est qu'elle est
quand même relativement fine arts pour
une tablette elle pourrait paraître
assez grosse mais pour une machine
polyvalente de ce style là mais je
trouve plutôt bien pour un ordinateur n
est pas très lourde elle fait 771 g dans
la plus petite configuration avec
l'intel core i5 et sans voir paris dans
quelques instants
ce qui est vraiment cool cette année
c'est qu'on a une nouvelle couleur la
couleur noire avant la dcan grille là
vous avez ce noir qui est très élégant
très efficace et très sympa
personnellement j'aime beaucoup les
finitions sont vachement bien ça les
traces de doigts fins il ya quelques
petites traces qui restent comme ça au
passage mais c'est vraiment trois fois
rien petit logo vous allez retrouver là
bon bouton pour l'allumer bouton de
volume ya rien de bien avec les
connectiques je vous en parlais dans
quelques instants
maintenant il ya tout qui fait pas
forcément l'unanimité vous avez quand
même des grandes bordures noires sur le
côté et c'est vrai que alors qu'on est
dans une évolution où on va plutôt sur
des choses assez fine que ce soit sur
les smartphones ou sur les tablettes
avec des bordures assez fine tout de
suite ça donne un look pas hyper hyper
hyper actuelle et c'est peut-être un
petit peu un point de regrets du point
de vue design parce que sinon le reste
est vraiment top
à côté de ça ça vous permet d'avoir la
caméra ici pour venir le déverrouiller
avec la reconnaissance biométrique de
votre visage ça s'est vraiment bien avec
windows hello je vous en parlais aussi
dans quelques instants
mais un truc que j'aime beaucoup aussi
c'est cette charnière je trouve vraiment
bien aussi on a vraiment une grosse
sensation de robustesse
lorsque vous la manipuler elle se défile
pas d'impact glissé trop vite sont
vraiment allés la poussée vous pouvez la
positionner comme vous voulez c'est
vraiment très pratique ça vous permet de
lavardens plusieurs modes vous pouvez la
voir en mode un peu tablette dans ce
format là un petit peu classique vous
l'avez ans le studio vous venez la
couche est comme ça lorsque vous allez
venir avec un stylet et après lorsque
vous l'a relevé comme ça et que vous
porter le clavier ça vous le met en mode
ordinateur tout simplement comme ça
c'est vraiment pratique
maintenant il ya également au point
qu'ils étaient améliorées c'est la
partie de l'écran on a toujours un écran
pixel sense à l'écran de 12,3 pouces de
diagonale avec une résolution de 2736
par 1824 pixels à 267 pixels par pouce
c'est toujours un écran tactile c'est
toujours un écran qui marche
parfaitement bien le tactile est super
la qualité de l'écran est vraiment bien
par contre ce qui est nouveau là tu sais
que l'écran est plus lumineux que la
génération précédente
côté performances et tourne avec un
intel core de huitième génération soit
un i5 soit un i7
il ya soit 8 gigas de ram soit 16 giga
de ram et dans l'absolu son côté de
machines qui est peu plus performante
que la génération d'avant on d une
amélioration des performances par
rapport à la génération précédente après
tout dépend complètement de votre
utilisation si vous faites tourner des
logiciels qui demande beaucoup de
ressources vous allez vous en rendre
compte si maintenant vous êtes plus sûr
de la bureautique si vous utilisez des
tableurs et s'il soir vous regarder des
séries des films c'est plus dans le côté
multimédia
je suis pas sûr que vous vous rendez
compte de la différence à ce moment là
la génération précédente pourra
probablement vous convenir et a raconté
un autre temps qui vachement intéressant
c'est que cette machine là elle est
hyper silencieuse lorsque vous
l'utilisez je trouves pas qu'elle choque
particulièrement et surtout en
glissement il est hyper silencieux et ça
c'est vraiment hyper confort côté
stockage vous avez trois possibilités
soit 128 giga de stockage qui à mon avis
est quand même relativement futiles sur
cette bécane vous conseille pas d'aller
faire du 100 m giga soit 256 gigas qui à
mon avis ne commence à être intéressant
face en 12 giga pour moi c'est vraiment
bien
soit carrément un terrain mais là par
contre vous allez pour aux besoins de
stockage
mais sur cette machine là ça peut aussi
éventuellement avoir un sens l'autonomie
aussi amélioré par rapport à la
génération précédente par contre
j'arrive pas aux 13 5 heures donné par
microsoft je suis plus autour des 8
heures à quelque chose près ça va
vraiment dépendre de ce que vous allez
en faire ça va dépendre de vos usages
il va y avoir une vraie différence si
vous regarder des séries ou si l'autre
côté vous êtes sur des applications qui
seront faits plus gourmandes de nomi va
varier en fonction de vos usages de vos
besoins de ce que vous allez en faire
donc c'est toujours compliqué vous
donner un résultat en tout cas ce qu'il
faut vraiment savoir c'est que
l'autonomie est quand même relativement
améliorée par rapport aux modèles
d'avant moyens toutefois qu'elle suis
pas hyper hyper convaincu c'est la
connectique parce que je trouve qui nous
manque des choses qui aujourd'hui sont
pourtant essentielles vous avez de lui
b trois bons crois pas c'est un peu
classique vous avez un display port
vous avez une prise jack qui est caché
de l'autre côté ici ça c'est aussi bien
et vous avez ici de quoi connecter votre
clavier type cover aujourd'hui le virage
a été pris sur les sbc l'usbc devient
standard et je trouve que c'est dommage
que sur une machine comme ça qu'il ya
même une machine haut de gamme on
retrouve pas de port usb c'est ça aurait
pu avoir un sens pour venir recharger
l'ordinateur sans pour avoir un sens
pour le connecter à d'autres machines
assez simplement je trouve ça un peu
frustrant d une prise usb un peu
standard mais qu'on n'est pas d'huez les
c'est sur cette machine
je pense que ça c'est un point qui va
être amélioré sur la surface pro 7
mais vu qu'on est quand même en 2019 je
trouve ça dommage que microsoft est pas
anticipé cette question là et n'est pas
mis de lui ai laissé là dessus on tourne
bien évidemment sur un windows disent
qu'on peut utiliser aussi bien en mode
pc comme ça un peu standards qu'on peut
venir utiliser comme ça également en
mode tablette côté sécurité vous avez la
puce tpm 2.0 et surtout vous avez
windows et l'eau pour venir les
verrouiller parce que vous avez de
reconnaissance biométrique de votre
visage et c'est vraiment très facile à
déverrouiller justement pour le
déverrouiller facilement vous avez une
caméra de 5 mégapixels à la banque qui
vous permet de filmer en 1080p bon ça ça
me servira notamment pour faire de la
visioconférence par skype parce que vous
voulez ça marche très très bien et à
l'arrière vous avez ici une caméra de 8
mégapixels qui vous servira également
pour de la conférence pour filmer ce que
vous avez à côté de vous mais bon voilà
on n'est pas sur un appareil photo
defour pas faire des photos de dingue
mais ça vous servira vraiment pour le
côté plus bureautique à savoir vous avez
également deux micros sur cette machine
pour pouvoir communiquer facilement que
ce soit d'un côté ou de l'autre et vous
avez des hauts parleurs ici de chaque
côté qui sont très très bien caché vous
en avez un là vous allez deuxième qui
situent juste là vous avez donc des haut
parleurs stéréo avec du son dolby ça ça
marche aussi très très bien côté
multimédia ça marche bien l'écran est
vraiment de qualité pour ça c'est
vraiment vraiment cool surtout comme
vous lisez avec des haut-parleurs stéréo
vous avez quand même relativement sont
deux petits haut parleurs de chaque côté
comme le positionnement est vraiment
idéal en façade ça vous envoie du saut
directement c'est vraiment pas fait donc
à ce que le deuil aussi maîtriser
surtout l'emplacement de la prise jack
eh bien voyez juste là en haut il ya
beaucoup de sons il ya un très bon
spectre pour écouter également qu'à ça
qu'une prise jack ça marche parfaitement
bien il ya d'autres points qui est
vraiment bien c'est le clavier vous avez
un retour de touche qui est vraiment
agréable le fait que vous puissiez leur
remontée comme ça voyez ce que
normalement ils seraient comme ça hop
voulu remonter ça vous
de l'angle alors c'est pas tout nouveau
ça sur ce type de clavier mais c'est
vraiment bien et puis surtout la le
toucher en alcantara
c'est hyper lourd hyper agréable et
lorsque vous leur montée comme ça ça
vous protège votre ordinateur
c'est bien vous pouvez l'emmener partout
avec vous donc on est un clavier qui a
une double fonction sas effectivement
pas une nouveauté cette année mais ça
marche toujours très très bien non plus
à nos toits qui est primordial là tu
sais qui s'installe très facilement
regarder il est aimanté vous venez de
poser en face il se relève qui se pose
pour voir le clavier est vendu à part en
option pour moi c'est pas du tout une
option ce clavier il est obligatoire
parce que c'est tout l'adn de cette
machine si vous l'achetez uniquement
pour avoir une tablette
vu le prix de la bécane pour - vous
passez à côté du truc le vrai intérêt
c'est pouvoir avoir le clavier avec le
stylet en plus pourquoi pas ça peut
avoir un sens mais en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que ça le clavier tim
powers il est strictement obligatoire
alors bien évidemment c'est une machine
qui a du wifi et du bluetooth 4 points
il ya un autre point qui aurait pu être
assez intéressant peut-être pour les
années à venir
c'est le fait de pouvoir loger une carte
sim à l'intérieur pour voir de la
bataille vous connecter partout internet
vue compter sur un produit qui est
vraiment fait pour la mobilité pour un
côté très pratique vous prenez vous le
posez partout vous pouvez bosser
regarder des séries lorsque vous voulez
partout vous n'avez pas la possibilité
est là dessus d'insérer une carte sim
pouvoir d'état ça peut être un point de
regret peut-être que dans les années à
venir c'est quelque chose qui va être
amené à évoluer et maintenant la
question qui fâche
combien ça coûte combien coûte cette
jolie machine cette surface pro 6 j'ai
tout noté la 12ème appris par coeur il y
en a près malinois configuration tu es
une offre à tiroirs vous avez soit un
processeur intel core i5 i7 de huitième
génération soit saisie agréable soit et
8 gigas de ram soit 128 go de stockage
256 512 ou alors carrément un terrain
alors si l'on reprend un peu diront sur
la version i 5 8 gigas de ram 128 go de
stockage vous pourrez trouver à 1069
euros 256 4369 euro à savoir que les
deux modèles sont disponibles en gris si
vous le voulez endroit faudra forcément
arriver sur le modèle avec 256 go de
stockage
quand on arrive sur le vice est le i7
vous avez une première version d'entrée
de gamme les grandes guillemets sur dix
8,7 avec 256 go de stockage à 1669 euros
vous trouverez en gris et en noir
ensuite vous arrivez sur le 16 giga de
ram toujours sur le lit 7 512 ya de
stockage 2069 euros vous trouverez en
gris noir ensuite uniquement gris le i7
16 giga de ram un terrain de
1469 euros c'est forcément relativement
cher ça commence à faire un joli prix
vous rajoutez à ça le clavier signature
kipco woerth qui est juste magnifique
qui pour moi est un accessoire comme je
voulais dit indispensable on peut pas
acheter lançant l'autre si vous achetez
le clavier son ordinateur c'est
complètement stupide si maintenant vous
achetez votre surtt uniquement votre
tablette je trouve que vous êtes
vraiment limité et vous allez mettre
beaucoup d'argent pour un produit dont
vous allez pas utiliser toutes les
capacités
c'est vraiment ça ces deux produits qui
marchent ensemble et là il ya un réel
intérêt
le clavier qui le cover et coûte 179
euros 99
en plus de ça ce qui peut être
intéressant c'est d'acheter le stylet
surface et pourquoi pas la souris
surface arc celui qui coûte 89 euros 99
et le stylet surface 109 0 80 euro si
vous prenez la première config avec le
clavier avec le stylet avec la souris
vous arrivez à 1400 48,97 senti ça fait
un joli prix
bon le style et décidera plus à des
infographistes des personnes qui vont
vraiment avoir besoin sinon c'est
tactile ou alors avec le petit trackpad
pour venir david et ça marche très très
bien il est vraiment très pratique
utiliser les suis absolument aucun
problème
vous êtes quand même à un peu plus de
1200 euros
voilà donc cesser c'est pas non plus
quelque chose de pas trop trop cher
néanmoins c'est vraiment une bonne
machine se trouve vraiment très
intéressante en terme de performance
vous serez pas déçu je lis l'écran est
bien falloir jeu je vous refaire tourner
la vidéo où tout est expliqué dans ce
conflit a dit alors regardé depuis le
début moi ce que j'aime vraiment
là-dessus sont les finitions du produit
je trouve que microsoft a vraiment une
très très belle gamme ça c'est pas
nouveau sur cette gamme la de la surface
pro ce qui est bien là c'est qu'on aura
cette nouvelle couleur noire qui est
toujours très sympa on a un écran qui
est un peu plus lumineux ça c'est ça
c'est aussi agréable lorsque vous allez
à l'extérieur et qui a du soleil c'est
bien c'est pas magique mais c'est quand
même relativement bien l'état forme ans
a crû de tommy a cru ça c'est vraiment
d'époque sont vraiment très très très
positif
maintenant ce qu'ils aient un petit peu
regretter c'est la connectique se disent
pas du sbc que je regrette mais qui
n'est pas encore d'activité sur ce
produit c'est le fait qu'ils ne puissent
pas avoir de carte sim avec de la data
lorsque vous vous déplacez ça c'est
vraiment un point de détail mais ils ont
retrouvé qu'il ya un sens la danse de
rue de lachine lequel n'a plus de 1000
euros de s'arrêter de bien qu'on puisse
mettre une carte sim à l'intérieur c'est
parce que vous en pensez comment vous la
trouvez cette surface pro sixième
version ces deux couleurs noir vous avez
comme ça vous trouvez ça pas mal qu'est
ce que vous en pensez à ce que vous en
avez une génération précédente est ce
que vous l'avez acheté celles là et
est-ce que vous l'utilisez sans clavier
utilisant que j'avais dit toi parce que
je trouve ça quand même surprenant qu'on
puisse l'acheter sans clavier je sais
pas après tout pourquoi pas vous invite
à me dire tout ce que vous en pensez
dans les commentaires
et puis si vous avez des questions ou
interrogations suggestion de pouvez y
aller juste hommage je donne rendez vous
dès demain va continuer à parler
peut-être beaucoup de choses qui
arrivent beaucoup de surprises toutes
choses intéressantes donc on reste
connectés
soyez sykes vous embrasse il ya demain
châu
m